Film Courage: Looking at your IMDB it shows
that you are you said kind of this one man
band.
You are a writer, director, producer, editor,
cinematographer, visual effects, camera.
Looking back do you wish you had spent more
time just kind of focused on being a writer
or was that a natural evolution?
You needed to find what you really loved the
actual activity of?
Logan Burdick: Filmmaker/Writer: Most of that
and again I have an interesting parable that
I do feel relates to that.
Everyone bear with me for a second…so when
I graduated USC I did a big thesis film and
I raised money and I tried do a big coming
out party.
It failed abysmally.
lt's fine but it literally led to no opportunities.
I owed a bunch of money and basically I had
two choices then which was well I can't make
any I can't I can't ask anyone for any more
favors I can't ask anyone for more money so
either I don't make anything anymore or I
start taking it upon myself to teach myself
all these trades at least in a way to be competent
at them so I can keep making things and so
that's basically where that all came from
was I wanted to keep making stuff because
I said oh this thing that I’d I tried a
big shot at collapsed I it but again it did
not do anything from a professional career
perspective but I want to keep having chances
and I want to keep trying so I'm going to
have to do this I'm going to have to practice
you know cinematography and I'm going to have
to become an editor and I'm going to have
to do all these things otherwise I just kind
of I'm not going to be able to keep making
things and that really interestingly led me
down the direction of youtube and digital
because then I could one man band shows or
pilots and that I made a pilot for a series
that I thought was really awesome and I got
pitched to and I basically I did everything
myself I got pitched to a really big digital
company at the time called Maker Studios and
the executive who hired me was I don't know
what to do with this particular show but would
you come on and do this for another show here
and the other thing about myself is anytime
I've been struggling financially it's difficult
to pay the rent or my day job is too engrossing
that I can't focus on my own creative pursuits
I knew fairly early on that I needed to find
a very specific situation that allowed for
enough stability but also enough freedom that
I could keep pursuing the things that I was
passionate about and so in this very weird
roundabout way teaching myself to one-man
band a digital series then led to my employment
doing that so that then I had enough freedom
and mental space that I could come home and
I could write or I could write on the weekend
and I wasn't because previous to that I'm
doing all sorts of just really odd odd jobs
and random things but that I couldn't concentrate
because I was too stressed and so yes so basically
in this very weird way teaching myself all
those crafts and then being able to apply
them on digital shows allowed me the freedom
to keep writing so again it's a very roundabout
way that that worked for me but I forget exactly
what my thesis is but it was probably something
along the lines of figure out what works for
you and understand that it's it's never going
it's never probably going to be the the paint
by numbers situation I guess can we go back
to the party in the in the film I guess so
you you did this thesis film at USC and then
you threw an event a screening or I meant
coming out party in the debutante way but
yes I did have I did have a screening sorry
go ahead oh no but I’d love to hear more
about it just because I'm just curious what
was the goal you were hoping that maybe prospective
employers would would find out in in and you
would then land a job yeah well that's the
other that is a little bit of the other problem
right is I think that when you're young you
can even have talent and you can have ambition
and you can have all sorts of positive qualities
but you also don't really know how the whole
system works real well and I think that now
friend I have a I've been gearing up other
independent projects right to do with you
know producers I know or talent and that thing
and a lot of people I know have been putting
pressure on me for a long time to do something
that again and my thought has always been
not not until I feel the dominoes are set
up correctly and I'm going to be a little
bit more risk adverse than in that way than
other people but but to me that's also what
I kind of learned from doing it when I was
young and going well I again time energy money
and I didn't really know what happened after
that I'm sure I had vague notions of someone
will give me an opportunity excuse me but
you have to be a lot more specific you know
you have to have a strategy and a plan if
you're going to go down that route and so
again to me it's important to fail because
that's how you learn and then hopefully you
can take those lessons and then you can apply
them later on in a situation where you go
okay now I have a much better sense about
how this is all supposed to go down to give
me the best chance at being successful or
letting giving this project the best chance
to be successful was it really a failure or
just that you had such high expectations for
it I do think that again for something to
be the most successful version of itself it's
obviously fulfilling goals that you hoped
it fulfilled and in this case that movie did
not fulfill said goals but again from the
point of view of just having the experience
and doing it and learning everything you do
through that that is also invaluable obviously
that it's a very trite cliche thing to say
but you you do need to learn by doing especially
in this situation I do think that however
you can mitigate your risk the most that you
can because again in this world mistakes are
expensive usually not always but but they
even even small projects you know you lose
money when they don't do whatever you were
expecting them to do
again I think that it's very important to
try to create a scenario in which you can
keep trying
I feel I feel if I had ever been in a situation
in which my one my one shot failed then I'm
sure I would have never had any opportunity
to achieve any level of success whatever that
means because it takes a lot of tries and
it takes a lot of failures and so then I think
the question really is for any individual
how do I create a scenario in which I'm allowed
to do that because that is hard right for
me I've always been very lucky because I have
a lot of friends who are very talented actors
and because they were talented actors and
we have a very good relationship and they
trust me to do what I do that then they would
always be willing to put their money into
projects so we could keep doing stuff together
you know or again I would also then at the
same time be going literally on youtube and
what watching video co-pilot I don't even
know if video co-pilot's still around they
they probably are there's something it and
learning how to do special effects and learning
how to again how to be a better again I'm
not a great DP by any means but at least competent
because that's available to you and then again
whatever situation allows you to keep taking
chances because it's a it's a batting average
thing you know if you're only up at bat once
yeah maybe you hit it but you're probably
not going to you're that's just the reality
so it's how do you how do you figure out how
to keep having chances at bat however whatever
that means to you I guess and once you realized
this was quote unquote a failure in your eyes
maybe not to other people what did you then
start doing to say okay well maybe it wasn't
my one shot and now I have to try it another
way I think that that to me um
one thing that that experience taught me was
to be a lot more interest I’ll be a lot
more interested in this idea of film as a
business and this idea because my my thesis
was was very wacky right it was just it's
very odd it did not fit neatly into any box
and I think that that was there was a couple
issues and I think that was one issue because
it was well this is probably too strange for
the for the industry for the average person
looking to do business with you where does
this go it did not neatly fit into any box
and again there are individuals who come out
of the gate with something really unique and
avant-garde and pushing the boundary and all
sorts of these things and and they are rewarded
for it's important for everyone to realize
that that's not everyone there is obviously
everyone wants things that are new and exciting
and they want the new and everyone wants to
know what the new cool flavor is and what
is gonna get people excited to go see this
movie but there is this very real business
aspect to it that if you ignore that you kind
of do that at your own peril and I think the
other thing that I thought going into it was
you do something a short for an opportunity
just to be hired to do something and again
I do that does happen but I do think that
if I were to do it again I would have been
a lot more specific about you know things
that seem obvious now where it's you do a
short that is from a feature that you've also
already written and that feature is marketable
right or that idea what are the very specific
concrete steps that this that this project
is a part of again trying to feed into the
idea of it's an industry and a business versus
looking at it as someone wanting to say oh
you're
we're just gonna pick you out because you're
so talented and again that does happen for
people but it doesn't happen for everyone
and then the question ultimately becomes okay
if that didn't happen for me then what can
I do to keep trying.
What was the most helpful part of this video
for you?